c'est une des curiosités de la plaine
des palmistes on y vient à pied par un
sentier boueux bordée de goyavier et de
chèvrefeuille et on découvre au bout du
chemin la cascade biberon et sont
limpides bassin mais d'où lui vient son
nom
plutôt bien avec les jeunes je les lui
tout à l'heure dans le routard mais j'ai
oublié et n'a pas de sens les jambes ne
peut-être boire un coup ici l'origine la
cascade et peut-être aussi à ces jeunes
et ils montrent d'autres escales où
d'autres auraient versé peut-être nom de
la personne à qui j'ai vu quelque chose
c'était grâce à monsieur c'est à cause
d'un garde forestier qui s'appelait
livrons de l'office national des forêts
cette cascade tient son nom d'un
personnage de caractère
jean baptiste biberons est né à bordeaux
en 1767 mousse des 13 ans ils écument
les mers du sud et effectue son premier
voyage d'affaires à bourbon en 1786 il
s'installe ensuite à l'ile-de-france en
là ils se marient à marianne deniaud
quelques mois plus tard le couple
divorce pour incompatibilité d'humeur
une décision particulièrement original
pour l'époque et puis à la surprise
générale les voilà qui se remarient deux
ans plus tard mais l'union se brise
encore en 1801
entre deux querelles jean baptiste a
fait trois enfants à marianne et à
passer l'examen de commandant de
bâtiments de commerce
sa passion pour la mer il la transmettra
à ses deux fils
sillonnant les océans il retourne dans
sa ville natale et épouser en troisièmes
noces sa propre nièce marie biroleau en
ils auront quatre enfants mais seul le
dernier louis rené naîtra à bourbon où
le couple s'installe définitivement en
c'est à saint paul que la famille fera
souche
et c'est aussi dans cette commune que
jean baptiste mourra le 19 juillet 1826